because money is going to follow you
when you're doing the right thing
and your work with the right people and
it doesn't have to be immediate but it
always will that's my experience
[Music]
irena meyer thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders
thank you thank you very much for having
me i love your show
thank you you have such a non-linear
path that i can't wait to dive deep and
understand
how your values are are progressing you
through your different life decisions
but
you know as a brief intro which will do
no uh
no service to the incredible things
you've done first of all you're an
emmy award winner let's put that out
there i can't wait to hear what that's
about but you actually started
or you didn't start you progressed
through financial institutions like bank
of america
you're a huge investor and i think
international investor because you speak
six languages i have to understand what
that's about
irina talk to me who are you what is
that how do you do all this stuff
i don't know i just do things which the
most normal the most natural for me
which means um i
i always do the thing that i feel is the
right thing
i walk away from the people who are
wrong people and i think that's very
important
and i follow the passion that i have
and i always at any point in time
uh make sure that i give back so
anytime i fail and or
i'm a bad situation i push forward
anytime
i win i have to pose and make sure that
i
share my success with other people who
also need a break
so that's kind of how i roll and also i
learn all the time i never
i never stop learning i love it i just
love it okay so
so talk to me how do you start from a
place like bank of america
and then move on to a place like abc
motion pictures when
emmy what's that about so um
i was working in uh um indeed in the
technology group i was
at the bank of america and it's actually
in the beginning was the um
countrywide uh and i was working doing
the technical risk
assessments uh for the
central group which means for the
headquarters all the
projects of the value above 20 million
dollars
of business impact will go for me then
um when 2008 happened
and i just was
seeing what was unfolding with the
countrywide
that no matter how good the 200 people
around me were
the company was deeply corrupt and
who created such an incredibly
devastating trickle effect or
contributing to it in the country
and even though i just was promoted four
months prior
to uh adp i walked away
because i never wanted and i didn't have
another job lined up
because that just i knew that was not
right
and that was me walking away from the
wrong people and i didn't want to create
any kind of
explanation for myself why i should stay
so
irina on that note what what so you
mentioned right at the offset
that the you you're guided by your
values and
that guides your non-traditional
non-linear path well what are these core
values that you're addressing here
absolutely so you need to make sure that
your word being contributed
to something good great good you do not
give
away your work for something
which is meaningless or have some kind
of short-term pragmatic
effect it's just not for me whenever i
work
it's really need to be to make better
the
uh social environment it needs to be
towards the creativity
it needs to be for the better of the of
the people
if it does not go there it just it stops
for me
and i know that i have quite significant
success and i have my personal
uh capital fund that's i run and it's
international
but i never followed what will be my
short-term or even mid-term uh financial
gain
because money is going to follow you
when you're doing the right thing
and your work with the right people and
it doesn't have to be immediate but it
always will that's my experience
inspiring okay so moving on to
a digital media and television and the
emmys
what is this industry that i have not i
don't know anything about it so so
you go what does that mean even digital
media and making those innovations over
there
of course so um digital media progresses
so what is it today in 2020 is very
different from what it was
in 2010 so
uh when i was there digital media it is
the way to
uh for the people to connect with
whatever they love
so it doesn't have to be for the network
television
i was working for abc but on the digital
media that means
that uh whenever they were oscars and i
was running oscar's production for the
three years
is to bring the experience to the
people not make it not leave it as an
elite
you know you just there is on some kind
of magazine cover
angelina julie and you have no relation
you create those bridges you connect it
here your
laptop your computer you in and many uh
uh of the um ios devices androids
you bring it to people how to make it
relevant to you
and every time and every day of working
in digital media that's what we were
doing
may if it is about oscars make sure you
are there
that means that the congress that i
would supervise to put in
the you every person from millions
connecting to the live stream
they had an impression that they can
move it at any point
and uh they can't be there and watch
what people do
during their their during the commercial
breaks
and that is that is really fascinating
because
that's what we want we do not want to
just
be on the outskirts we want to be part
of the show and that's what the digital
will do
so what are some of the challenges that
you faced as you were trying to innovate
the
this concept so what does that even mean
for for me to sit at home and be present
at the oscars
for example um you
um you are invited
that's that's the thing you receive the
golden envelope you invited
you can choose to go and see uh
where the stars take a champagne you can
decide what dress
a trophy girl i'm not being obnoxious
it's an official name called trophy girl
the girl who brings their
that brings the oscar that's that's the
position what
will should be wearing and that will be
competition
among like 10 different upcoming
totally annoying designers unbelievable
people can
be present at their catwalk which will
be done before and
and the winner will be announced during
this time
that means that's on the red carpet it
will be your digital media host
by the way we had outboard right next to
oprah's
and then where we will be talking for
our
funds for our viewers from
from home not necessarily just bringing
more people to the abc
channel so that the abc channel will
sell more ads
it's for the people who can just log on
their phone
and or on their tablet and just be there
and their questions will be answered
amazing but that's
radically different from you know being
an investor you're investing in early
stage startups yet here you are being a
creative
you know you're running creativity to
how to integrate
you know the at-home experience with
something like as
amazing as the oscars and by the way you
got the emmy in 2011 for and what was
that for for innovation in digital media
yes it was outstanding achievement
in interactive media unbelievable also
the product was um oscar's digital
experience so that's the whole package
that we did
and that's we were unfolding for the
five months prior to the show we
recorded we created four television
shows for our web presence
we did the meetings with the
stars with the nominated stars they were
designer contests they were sweepstakes
there were many things
prior to the event so the whole package
of
it was oscar's digital experience
and we rolled it out on
ios only um
it was barely eight months after ipad
was out
and it's too um i believe
three years till something similar were
rolled out by
somebody else which was mtv later on so
yeah it was actually a big deal from
technological perspective i worked with
over 20 different
contractors in addition to over
um 15 of different internal groups for
abc
and the infrastructure groups at the
disney which is a foreign company of abc
unbelievable unbelievable okay and then
let's move on to
your to investment so you're running an
early stage fund you're investing
internationally which is
which is unique in its own way because
most venture capital funds
especially early stage they're focused
on on a certain geographical region yet
you're
you're branching out and is that because
he speaks six languages
is that is that a part of it no i'm not
sure because
i learn languages for years before they
eventually become useful because it is
so um it is it helps
when it comes but i am once again i
avoid
this uh uh pragmatic effect why don't i
learn german so i can invest in
switzerland
or in it's it happens in in a similar
way or why do
i learn mandarin chinese for the last 10
years
and it's only year ago when i became my
board member for a company which is
doing development in china
so it comes eventually together but it's
not because of that
and i agree with you this is not
conventional i'm the only person in my
company the fund
is my personal i don't have any lps
and for an individual a one-woman
operation
to say you know u.s is not enough
i made only last year six investments in
israel
and i invested in a swiss company and
i'm a and i'm
planning to do more i'm a member of two
groups
uh in surikan and zug and
uh um yeah it is
um but the reason to the magnet
i am not just being
trying to overextend myself i plan
specifically
let's say when i go to israel i have a
plan
what is it what type of company interest
me what type of innovation
what groups i need to work i know what
proportion
of my portfolio i want to be dedicated
to this specific area which is med
device life science
in israel which i find absolutely
extraordinary
and that i wanted to be within about
25 to 30 to 33 of my portfolio
and i just worked diligently for a very
long
time before i trigger my investments but
whenever they're ready
i'm very decisive and i'm just going and
i'm executing it
same thing that i would do in
switzerland and recently i invested even
in a company
out of sofia bulgaria my very first
east european wow but how do you even
how do you even find these companies
because the deal flow is its own
struggle there's so many
you know early stage vc's around the
world now i don't know how many there
are in eastern europe but but around the
world
in israel and and us of course there's a
lot so how do you go and find those
deals so that when you want to be
decisive and execute
you actually have access to the best
deals
so that is an absolutely wonderful
question
and that is the biggest issue i think
that's exists with
private investors right is to have
access to the deal flow
and be able to see through correctly
and i've been very fortunate
in the fact that i've been able to
create an extraordinary
network and because i'm never afraid to
walk away from something that doesn't
work or being very outspoken when
something is subpar
that i have really
wonderful collaborators and i spend huge
amount of my time
perhaps over 80 of my time doing
pro bono work for other investors okay
when i do that
and i do not ask for any and that goes
back to my core values
and i do not ask for shares or payment
of any kind
i will get back the most interesting
deals these people will be working on
and they will be sharing it with me that
they might be even
reluctant to do with somebody else and
it's not only with private individuals
vcs like partners and bc firms will
reach out to me and say
hey irena i came across that that's our
fund is investing
and uh would you like to have some space
in the round
and uh that is uh
that i think is uh it's all about
relationships creator
for me versus many other private
investors
so it's all about the relationships and
it sounds like again the the pro bono
work that you're doing and all these
different
experiences and the values that you're
exuding they're not about getting
something in the short term you think
you're saying
i'm operating my life in the long term
and and if i'm
if i'm kind and if i'm helpful to others
now i'm not expecting anything in return
but
but you know accumulatively over years
these relationships
are these relationships go both ways and
it's not just that they're helping me
they want me to be
in a partnership with them because they
know that my values are
are true and honest yeah and oftentimes
it doesn't come true and i'm completely
okay with that
sometimes people just consume the piece
of work i've done
and then that's it and you know what i
never have a hard feelings about it
because
i know that i'm doing the right thing
and that says that is it
and the access to the most interesting
innovative company to the ceos who need
mentorship we need help who needs
introduction
and it's everything that i do is
collaborative
every single thing i never just find a
german says okay that is just for me i
hope nobody hears about it
i don't want to do any work for them
because it would be free
no i will tell about it and i will help
sometimes i do work for they see
for the company and for a ceo for years
without
even being an official advisor because
that is how i can help my companies
to gain value and to come to the next
level of financing
reaching the new audience that
i'm not a passive investor and i think
it's also it's helps me to get
um much better results than probably on
average
in the space amazing irena what is it
about languages that you that you love
so much how do you get to learn
six languages and what are those six by
the way
well my mother language my mother chunk
is russian
and then obviously it's
english french i got in
i was in paris for a year and i learned
the french literature
and french language in paris and then
um i speak german
and that is my most recent language i
started learning chinese
back in 2006 or so um
i am quite fluent in mandarin i speak
spanish
fluently which definitely helps
um and i don't know maybe i missed
something well next one next one needs
to be hebrew of course
but as long as you know good stuff
because it breaks the barriers
between me and other people and other
cultures
and it makes my life richer because i
can read
i can watch tv in whatever language i
can travel and i can talk to people
and i am very people oriented and
i feel like my world is brighter
and bigger and happier and
then it would be as wise
i love it irena what is the one thing
you're most passionate about like what
gets you so excited
every single morning when you wake up
about the work that you do
about the work that i do yes it is
i feel like um an individual
have an opportunity to make a huge
effect
on the society at large and i'm not
talking about one country society
it is we i feel like i can
i am making a difference whether it is
from my volunteering work for the any
foundation
or whether it is by mentoring somebody
who brings the
new way of um
popularizing something that was used to
be available only to elite
or bring in the mitigation the new
molecules
that is gonna save lives and prevent
suffering
from women suffering from breast cancers
from
early diagnosis of the oral cancers and
it also
made difference for the life of
individual entrepreneurs
who strive with their dreams or in their
creative side well everything is
creative but
in their uh television arts
for the young people out of alabama
mississippi who want to be producers in
hollywood
you want to give them that chance and
when you can
by finding for them an internship in
with one of the studios you feel like
that day was a good day
and it's just for them it will be
nothing for me
but it feels more than anything else
that
uh i can receive in the form of payments
talk or something arena inspiring
inspiring
right before we leave i can't believe 20
minutes are already up i need three
words that best describe you and i want
to thank you for
really the generous time that you're
that you've given me here
so um that is a good question so number
one
will be decisive um so i am capable of
making decisions right
so that would be definitely passionate
passionate will be the second one
because
if i'm not passionate i just don't do it
and
um the third would be um i don't know
why but that's what
people seem to differentiate me from
others i know no fear so i'm absolutely
fearless there is no such a thing that
some
they can scare me decisive passionate
fearless irina
tadalaba thank you very very much we
didn't even talk about j ventures and
and and how i love collaborating there
but but but we'll leave that for another
time thank you for everything uh
really inspiring just thank you thank
you thank you
very very much and i hope to collaborate
sometime soon with perhaps my own
venture
so look out for the email would love to
please think of me like when you're
building something new
thank you take care bye bye